je suis mieux voire de protestation à la
face du fuel de grands travaux une faute
bénigne ont donc conduit déjà les dents
gic sûrement évoluer ce n'est pas être
dans leurs débiles que l'on décidera
finalement de faire machine arrière
parce que la chose sera encore plus
grave et effectivement le temps de
cancer de la torche un cancer et de 30
ans mais ne faut pas attendre que tous
les cancers se soit déclenchée pour
fonder mesures qui conviennent mais ce
cri d'alarmé prémonitoire n'émeut guère
les autorités les industries de
l'amiante occupe le terrain médiatique
et pendant 20 ans vu su se dégrade dans
le silence malgré quelques réparations
de fortune il faudra attendre 94 et la
reconnaissance des premières maladies
professionnelles pour relancer la
mobilisation avec le comité antienne
novembre 95 un rapport d'experts cause
le diagnostic le flocage est en état de
dégradation avancée une opération rapide
et massive d'enlèvement de l'amiante
s'impose 14 juillet 96 jacques chirac
relance au dos il annonce plus
d'étudiants a juste pas dans la fin de
l'année les questions se bousculent pour
y déménager et faire les travaux la
rentrée arrive étudiants chercheurs
toute la communauté universitaire
s'interroge elle a aujourd'hui une
première réponse